develops and manages oral history
projects and creates personal histories
on audio video and in print Elizabeth's
work is wide-ranging and includes
interviewing and interpretation for
survivors of the show of visual history
foundation to september's 11 2001
narrative the memory project at Columbia
and in addition Elizabeth has taught
workshops for the veterans history
project at the library of congress and
the mixed heritage oral history project
at the Brooklyn Historical Society she
is currently a consultant at large to
the Henry now an oral history project at
the Henry now an institute in Toronto
Canada Elizabeth has worked extensively
in Europe and she's going to talk about
her beginnings but she was the regional
project director in the United States
and Canada for the moth housing
survivors documentation project at the
University of Vienna she speaks many
languages including English German
Italian and understands French Spanish
Portuguese and Yiddish on her website
she very generously acknowledges the
expert colleagues and associates that
she works with and we are thrilled that
she is one of ours here some of her
great resources on her website just span
from books to authors to some reviews to
organizations and they run from
storytelling programs at st. John the
Divine here to books such as the
unauthorized biography of the world oral
history on the front lines by Michael
Riordan which is very fun to read and
organizations such as the International
Coalition of the sore excited country so
welcome thank you Mary and thank you for
this lovely introduction thank you so
much and I first thank you for inviting
me it's it's exciting and wonderful to
be here I love it and thank you for
listening to me I to those who have just
arrived I'm sorry I have a cold and my
voice is not my best voice so please
bear with me and try to keep it what I
what I would like to share with you is
really this journey of an interviewer
and I thought a that since you are all
involved in our own history I will need
to embed it as I would in an interview
in at least in part into my own life
history to show you why I'm doing the
things that I am doing and why my
journey is the way as it is and has been
and also I want to emphasize that I
really consider myself most of all in
interviewer because interviewing is that
what I think I really do best and where
I
I mean that's something that I thought a
lot as I was listening to to all of you
who who are now in this master's program
and you you you are on this journey
thinking what am I going to do next and
how will i integrate that what I've
learned into the actual life out there
we like will it be academia will it will
I get employed somewhere in a historic
society or in some organization and work
for them will I be independent will I do
something entirely different each of you
probably according to to your talents
into your experience and also that what
what unfortunately the circumstances are
well not very easy economy and life
situation will allow you believe will
find your way but what what I think that
I would like to show you with with
telling my story is that even if you
think you are totally stuck or even if
you think that you start at the
beginning that is entirely different
from that what you are achieving oyster
if you feel there's one barrier after
the next and then you try to work your
way around the barrier whatever you will
be doing if you if you have if you can
identify here in your solar plexus this
one thing that you want to do in your
life or the kind of activity where you
know that you're as I always call it
your souls that's fly if you if you
succeed to to get to that point then all
the rest will fall in place and then
also all the data in roads that you will
have to work a part of the story and you
will learn from them and they will cut
up with you strangely enough especially
the dead ends we cut to put you into
the next chapter while keeping somehow
in an open minded way the vision of what
you want to do and for me this is my
vision or that what I really love to do
as I said I'm not a scholar I'm not
really a researcher I do my observations
I I feel like a complete fraud in here
and in pasta if I tell you I haven't
even finished high school and I will
tell you why so but all that at the end
doesn't matter I had a I have a stepson
who is severely dyslexic and there where
he had to go to school to overcome his
dyslexia you have each house has the
name of a famous person it is an stein
and so forth they all were also totaled
school failures so am i i'm not putting
myself really definitely nothing to any
of that level of these people but that's
what when I saw that in my stepson what
encouraged me also to think okay even if
you don't finish high school you can you
can walk your way and i'll tell you how
it went i was born in 51 it's not that
it's not a secret i'm 16 years old and
the lady of a certain age but now and i
enjoy it and i was born in links which
is a tiny little not tiny actually it
wasn't in the States it would be a time
it's a ton of two hundred thousand
inhabitants and it happened to be a town
that used to be a very rural center of
commerce and then in the 30s because as
history so does it not far from there
adult fiddler was born he wanted to make
this into a center of Industry and he
did and he wanted to make it into one of
the of his three main metal of the main
centers of the third life the lean
Munich Linz in Austria in his home come
and I grew up in the 50s s I have a
brother who's younger who also didn't
finish high school so there must be some
reason why that is as the daughter of my
father Eric who had returned in 45 from
being incarcerated six years by Hitler
after having been put on trial because
he was one of the few who will resist it
here the resistance group and in 39 the
resistance group was betrayed and he was
put on trial with the rest of the group
was condemned to death and then because
of circumstances that are maybe too long
now to explain and to describe my
grandmother whose only son he was
succeeded to approach a high ranking
person in Berlin who wrote a letter to
the court and since he only wrote he
wrote a letter to the court saying that
the entire family was fabulous re and no
Jewish blood anywhere and somehow this
guy was the only black sheep in the
family so since they wrote that letter
the court knew that they couldn't only
late
when I did research in the archives my
beloved grandmother not only saved her
only son but she saved also the others
because since the head wasn't being
executed also the others were not
executed so they were all in prison
until 45 and so to have been for six
years in prison even coming back as
somebody who who came back and knew that
he had done the right thing but six
years of this kind of horror that you
undergo they did leave scars and I so I
grew up under the shadow of having a
father who was brilliant he had to to
postgraduate degrees he was on his way
to be a diplomat that's also how he then
also buy it was sooo politically
interested and became the head of the
resistance group he came back in 45 to
an Austria that was the reason why he he
went to prison he wanted to keep his
country free but to an Austria that was
very very changed and also in this tiny
town he knew that there were very very
few handful of people who had before the
war or during the Nazi occupation
similar views like him ninety-nine
percent of
happy Nazis so imagine now my family in
this kind of bubble because also my
mother had come from a family of
resistance her own father had was the
first political prisoner known to wish
who was beaten to death in tahoe so she
had she and her five siblings had lost
their father when she was a teenager and
so there was this little family in limbs
and surrounded by and yeah what I'm said
well surrounded by is something that I'm
and I Deb our our memory and issues that
we talked about before come really into
play is that I construct certainly money
my history and I construct what I
remember what I remember is obviously of
or very clearly to me a mixture of that
what I actually experienced in school I
mean I know that i was with the back
against the wall when I stood up and and
asked about certain historic events that
were totally clear to me but still were
not appropriate to talk about in the 50s
and
this in Austria or I will clearly
remember that when I would quote
something from everyday politics that I
had read in the newspaper that standing
there in the break people from my class
would come to me and say how do you know
this and I would say well that must have
been 12 years old and I said well I read
it this morning with my father in the
newspaper and they all looked at me as
if I came from the moon and said what
you allowed to lead the newspaper so so
imagine this this strange environment
where at home I have a father who who
had had been on the right side and it
was obvious that he had been under under
under on the side of those who who who
were not the perpetrators and to who
taught as children and that's that's one
of the reasons why probably we fade in
school but that's one of my
interpretations why we failed in school
he told us always ask questions ask
questions never take that what is being
told to you be it in the newspaper bid
on the radio beat by an authority be it
by by a teacher don't take a four and A
always try to go behind and figure out
for yourself is that what they tell you
is really true so I can imagine I don't
remember it but I can imagine that with
this kind of attitude probably I must
have been a real place to my teachers
because if you constantly question
things that are being present in post
post-war austria was still full of rules
and full of
of the attitudes that still reveye
brated from from the Third Reich so to
make the long story short when I was I
think 17 and that was the rigidity of
the system I stopped going to school
because in Austria at the time if you
went to school and you failed in one
subject at the end of the year you had
an opportunity to do another work for
the entire summer then make a test and
then you either failed or you didn't
fail and if you fail you had to go back
and repeat the entire here again so that
happened to me three times and when it
happened for the third time I was told
it's over you cannot continue your
education bits over not not like here in
the US while you're always having an
opportunity and the chance and you can
even go to college if you if you if you
show the right knowledge so yeah but
what should I do I was somebody who read
a lot I remember that at the time there
was a little public library and and I
had to bring several times when I was
growing up I had to bring my father to
the library he had to show up himself
and certify with his signature that he
was okay that I would read books that
were for grown-ups because I had already
read everything that was for my age
group and they just didn't have anything
new anymore so he came with me a few
times and sign that it would be okay
that I continue reading so I I fled into
reading and then a good thing happened
for me not so easy for my father he lost
his job and he and we moved to Vienna
and that was liberating in one sense
because it was
town and I thought that would somehow
give me more space and more
opportunities I found a kind of Academy
that gave me a two-and-a-half-year
program to be like an administrator I
did it was the time in the late 60s that
the European Union started to form and
since my father was a very political
person and the tint dinner table
everything we talked about was politics
and history and literature and so forth
I was interested somehow to get out of
little Austria so I found this Academy
that miraculously didn't require a
parking area and I went there and did
that Academy for two and a half years at
all it would be Asian in Austria it was
one yeah and in psychology in the
languages in economy at whatever but you
also needed to type and those were these
huge big mechanic typewriters and I
failed that test and I failed it three
times so I never got my my degree
because I didn't type fast enough and I
didn't type correct enough so then I
gave up so that was it I had it with
with official institutional schools and
I realized I wanted to look for a job
and I wanted to look for a job that
interested me so what I learned from my
father who by the way did a fabulous
thing when we were children when nobody
else in Austria still did it he would
pack us in a tiny little car my mother
my brother
died and we would go just out to Europe
somewhere we didn't even know exactly
where we were going we would go to
France we would go to Sweden we would go
to Holland whatever and on the road he
would always know where the best church
is where were the best restaurants where
we're the best ice cream was where the
best museums were with the most
interesting paintings and we did this so
that that somehow opened my my
dimensions in terms of thinking also
towards the outer world a bit and so
when I had to I was I think what was it
when it went that had failed like 21
years old here I was 21 and needed to
work so what does one do with no
credentials at all one starts like like
like an intern somewhere so I was
interested at the time I thought I
wanted to maybe do go into journalism
and so I wrote letters to all the
newspapers that were politically somehow
acceptable and to the Austrian radio and
TV and said I'm 21 and I'm interested
and can put you take me as in winter and
strangely is luck so has it the the
director of the Austrian radio and TV
news needed somebody actually I he
invited me for an interview said no
sorry and then I came here he called me
back and so for six years first for two
years in Vienna and then for another six
years actually I worked for the Austrian
we're doing TV first in Indiana and then
in Rome Italy so I learned Italian
was far away from from Austria knocked
geographically button and other sins and
what I what I started to to learn is I I
I found myself also mind my mother had
always been active in doing social work
so in hindsight I realized that I
started a kind of social service for
that what we're holocausts refugees
people from Austrian from Germany who
had landed in Rome and where nobody
really took care of them they were not
recognized as such at the time it was
still in the mid-70s many of them didn't
get any any reparations over any any
pension money or whatever so I started
working with the the embassy and the
consulate and there was a group of about
30 people that I had on my list and that
i visited regularly and somehow without
knowing I think I started to do our
history with them because I asked him
about their life stories and I listened
to them and unfortunately I didn't
record what they were saying but I
listened to their stories and learned so
much from him and then after six years I
realized that I was pushing 30 I knew
that I couldn't continue thereby I was
because there was just no advancing
in my work I worked with the
correspondent we were only two people in
Rome and I had I had experienced times
like 1978 that was the year of the three
popes so I had two funerals and 22
elections of a pope to help report about
I i was in 78 was also the year where
the Prime Minister was captured out
tomorrow and was kidnapped for 48 weeks
and then found dead so for about six
weeks I hardly ever left the building in
which our office was and also that
somewhere up my apartment was because we
would work around the clock to report
about that and so in when I was 30 I
decided I had to make a change went back
to Austria and got hired by an
international social service agency that
takes care of street kids keep children
and youth that have lost their parents
or I need of being retrained into new
jobs and since I had all this Italian
experience they sent me to Italy all
over Italy for several years to identify
in the most remote little places to
identify needs of free education so I
would go to the local Georgia would go
to the local social worker I would go to
the teacher and whoever and the end the
mayor and and identify projects that
then would be funded by the organization
that sent me down and that gave me the
extra component a in managing big
projects and be also to again look
behind the curtain as my father had
taught
me because I was not looking further for
the private school so I was not looking
for the rich part of office town or city
I was going really there by the needs
where and listen or try to listen and to
understand how best to help and then
make a suggestion to my to the directors
of the organization so we there were
about 50 projects all over southern
Italy northern is still in left and
right and while i was doing this i think
i have to speed up if i want to tell you
everything i found i came across my
husband my later husband because one
project the project for women better
there was a first house in Italy in
Milan for battered women and children
that was initiated in the in the early
80s nobody at the time in Italy I mean
Italy 30 years ago was still at least in
on the surface for everybody that the
miracle place where everybody loves
children and what it's paradise for
children which in many ways it is but i
think that was just-- still a lack of
sophistication to again look behind the
curtains and to see that the child abuse
and that the abuse of women is something
that unfortunately happens in every
society so a person who became my
mother-in-law with her own initiative
had started this this house and I heard
about it and that they needed further
funding and so I started working with
her and as I was doing this I happened
run into her son a few months later as i
was visiting again and he is a painter
and he at the time lived here in New
York so after he later I found myself in
New York continued to do from afar the
social service projects in Italy but
felt here a family with two teenage kids
in the household and my husband and very
soon my own daughter and found myself in
the in the New York art world of the
time in the midst of Soho had all these
people that I had no clue who they were
but they came to dinner and and slowly I
started to understand that many of them
at least had important shows all around
so at the time and I was incredibly busy
and enjoyed to be in New York far not so
much enjoying being far away from Europe
I somehow and missed my my European
origins and but was quite quite happy
with my life and then about almost nine
years into my marriage shorten my
marriage was over overnight as it
sometimes can happen and my stepchildren
at the time were already out and about
in college or independent and my
daughter was eight or nine and I found
myself in a sublet somewhere
the lower east side and try to figure
out what would come next because just to
make things even more complicated it
wasn't only that my my marriage was over
but also my work with the Italian
projects had to come to an end because
we had spent the money so either go back
to Europe birthday and I decided to stay
because of my daughter who wanted to be
close to her father which is her good
right and I think I did the right
decision in staying here but I had said
somehow cut all my ties back to Europe
and need to understand what next to do
and since I came from from journalism I
can't throw away magazines or newspapers
before I at least I have looked into
them and now I'm incredibly grateful
that we all start reading on the
internet because length I don't need to
read everything anymore so but at that
time it's now we are almost what is it
15 years ago I was depressed I had no
idea what would come next I had no job
and there was this pile of newspapers
that I hadn't looked at and New York
Times and before throwing them out and
to recycle I opened one after the other
just even if it's two weeks old just to
go through and suddenly I see and I
still remember it was on the right side
of the newspaper a big article Steven
Spielberg starting project to interview
Holocaust survivors and that they are
going to open an office here in New York
and that they are going to interview
2,500
people and that people who are survivors
should should call a certain number so I
was fascinated and intrigued because
also as I left and left Europe it was
still totally bare or mostly bare of any
kind of historic literature about that
time that only started after 85 and I
left in 84 and i found a wealth of books
here in New York that I started to
gobble up as I think to gobble up books
and so when I saw this I figured okay
they are looking for to interview 2,500
people maybe they are in need of
interviewers and I mean I knew I came
from journalism so at least it was worth
it right so I called the number and I
said hey you hear my accident it's no
doubt it's an Austrian X and I will
never lose it you don't see me but I'm
blonde and I'm definitely not Jewish but
this is also my story so if you need
interviewers I would really be
interested in being part and yeah it's
as it so sometimes happens when you just
have the guts to go for something it
happened and I became part of that group
and that was really my initiation into
oral history because suddenly everything
came together everything came together
personally because as I was interviewing
hundreds of people in listening to
hundreds of stories not that the
specific questions that I have would all
be answered but I think I came as close
as I could
because I also have to say that my
father whoo-hoo I would have interviewed
that I had understood that he would die
so early he died when I was only 28
years old so I can't go back to my
father and ask him stories I can still
go back to my mother who is 94 but I
cannot go back to my father and so with
the Spielberg project it also as it was
such a big project and what is so
wonderful about these big projects and
I'm so glad that sadie is here because
she is doing something in a similar way
on there on the small city from there
from the Brooklyn Historical Society a
oral history projects the way home I
love them are a team effort a group
group thing where we as the interviewers
learn incredibly much not only from the
narrator's but also from each other as
we are going along and what also started
happening was there with the shower
project which I think before had not
been thoughts ruled it well because it
evolved is not only did we teach each
other and help each other in the
research for the interviews in the
preparation for the interviews but what
was most important was the support
afterwards so what what for example I
can share with you is we had once a
one-week intensive up in the Catskills
because like some of you may know that
Jewish immigrants and Holocaust
survivors until very recently and some
sleep do would all go up to the
catskills in the summer
and be on vacation there was with their
children and with their grandchildren
and and oftentimes in hotels were
hundreds and hundreds of these families
what would come together so the Shoah
foundation decided that we would do a
week of intensive interviewing there so
imagine a Holocaust interview is
something that really drains here and we
committed to one week and two interviews
a day so it was really so intense
because each of you each of us had some
time somewhere a moment where we broke
down we were so high on adrenaline and
on it was like these deities incredibly
intense experiences so we really needed
each other to decompress afterwards we
needed each other to go for walks we
needed each other to make silly jokes we
needed each other to to to sing songs we
needed each other also to hug and to to
not be alone because something like that
you cannot do on your own and that these
these intensive days also had as a
result or maybe it wasn't just these
days but we reformed support groups for
each other because especially when it is
about stories of horror of terror of
genocide of all the most unimaginable
things we take these things in but we
also need to somehow get rid of them
afterwards and I cannot go home to
to a loved one in my family and tell
them about it because that wouldn't be
appropriate know what they really want
to hear it I think that's what then in
such an instance the group of support is
so I would really encourage all of you
when you do an intense project in the
future about the topic that's really a
complex one then then come fight with
each other for groups with each other's
support each other and help each other
because that we we really bring your
bring your two to it also in the quality
of what you are doing on there on a very
different level something because we
said i would i would also say anecdotes
indeed you were asking me before about
the memory and how we r memory changes
one thing came to my mind as i was
preparing for this in the in the course
of my hollow cast interviews there were
several people obviously who would talk
about being transported or being sent to
camps and coming through my hometown
because especially the Hungarians when
they were who were the last ones to be
sent to concentration camps in 43 44
they would need to travel west and the
route the main route was through my
hometown linds so I remembered to have
interviewed a beautiful woman a
Hungarian woman who was a child when
that
into her she wasn't such a train and she
talked about being that they were
thinking because they were among the
rich Hungarians and who the Nazis took a
lot and a lot of money from them
pretending that if they gave them all
that the state and all their money and
everything that they had they would fund
this train and the train would bring
them down south to Italy and from there
to Palestine which was complete life
they took the money and they all these
this rich Hungarian families boarded the
train and went West West West West so
the woman described that and the woman
described that they stopped in Linz and
I used this interview or they often to
to to speak about things and in my
memory she had talked about actually
really the train stations and the guards
being up on the on the balcony that I
knew so well in this big hard because
that was my childhood train station I
knew it so I could really visualize how
how that must have been and then about
half a year later or so there was an
oral history conference down in durham
and somebody from the Shoah foundation
called me and asked me to be part of a
panel and to use one interview as an
example and to talk about it and this
interview since he touched so much my
own history I felt was the one that I
wanted to talk about and I asked him to
send me the tape and I really wanted to
use this segment with the with the train
station as she was describing the SS
being up on the under
come here so far and I listened to it
and I listened to it and I can't find it
I can't find it it wasn't in there it
was just in my mind she talked about
coming schooling's and she talked about
being out there and and and then being
transported further but she didn't
describe the train station but since the
train station was so much in me I
integrated it and made it part of the
story and then the evidence of so that
was one of my very first big lessons in
also not trusting my own memories to
understand that every day I am
constructing who i am and every day if
you ask me tomorrow there will be
something different than that what I
tell you today so that was a really
really interesting experience but it was
still a good interview and it was about
my hometown to a degree but just not
about that but I remember me and after
after having done many many many shower
interviews for the speed bag foundation
by the way they also had a very had done
started a system that I also encourage
you if you ever run a larger project to
do they every other interview there was
a person assigned to me in California at
the Shoah foundation who would look at
the intima interviews probably not each
and every one in its entirety but and
then every few weeks she would call me
and we would have the kind of coaching
session and she would call me and we
will talk about certain aspects of the
interview that went especially when
I went not so well overcome in this was
so I learned so much from her and this
jessica we don't want she she became a
real real friend because it was amazing
what what I loved from her and it's so
useful so i encourage you to integrate
that in your project if you do yeah and
then the University of Vienna asked me
to become the original project director
for the mouth housing memorial history
project and that is about the Mauthausen
concentration camp which is a
concentration camp that's about five
miles outside of links which is also
something that I somehow grew up with in
the neighborhood of and we interviewed
about a hundred and ten into Holocaust
survivors here in the US which for me
was fabulous because it gave me i don't
know how many i did we were four
interviewers and we divided the country
in different areas and and would go out
there and interview people and it gave
me for the first time i didn't have that
opportunity to see the United States or
to see certain cities I had always I
mean I I'm always going back to Austria
to my family of origin or to my Italian
family but I I didn't have an
opportunity to see the US and that was a
fabulous way also of to see the
differences in
in this beautiful country and they again
this was I was the as well and
interviewer as as well that the project
director for the for the US and we were
four people interviewing and when that
ended that was almost the moment that I
had described in our discussion before
where I was at the end of my strengths
and energy to do this as an independent
person meaning not affiliated to a
university or a historical society or
whatever because I would have had
already months and months and months
before the project and it had started to
write grants for a next one next project
and a I didn't have any ideas I was just
burned out and so I was in the process
probably of thinking what might come
next and now I'm not sure of the
sequence yeah then came September 11 and
Mary Marshall called I had just finished
the Summer Institute and we started
interviewing and that again was a
fabulous lesson and I'm so grateful that
she designed it the way she did because
we did a first interview with the people
we ourselves identified because the
project obviously wasn't planned
September 11 happened we could identify
the group of people we wanted to
interview and since I had lived down in
soho and tribeca i mostly interviewed
women who wear mothers and self-employed
like
I was that was most of them but not
everyone and suddenly what what surfaced
was a wonderful distance between the
interviews we had a first interview
immediately in the first three months
after the event and then we went back
about a year a year and a half later and
again similar things happened has
happened with this woman in the story of
the woman in the index station I had
remembered certain events that somebody
told me about really differently then
when I actually got them on paper in the
transcript and then when I went to
interview them a third version of the
same memories would surface so there was
the first immediate memory right after
the event then a year later the
collective memory had said in we all had
seen certain images at zillion of times
we had certain stories at zillion of
times we integrated certain parts and
then we re-interviewed people and a year
or so later and that gave incredibly
fascinating very insisted that I would
love to go back to one day and and look
into a little closer what what I saw as
a pattern m
urge and also again like all life
histories that you just listen to this
one taught me the sense of home how how
we all in our need to have a sense of
home and even if that place that for us
is it signifies home is at the moment
the most dangerous one we still want to
go back to that and why am I saying that
I interviewed to two groups of women one
group were the women north of the towers
who lived in Tribeca or in Soho and many
of them had their their home businesses
at home and what they did when the
towers were hit they started running
towards the event they started running
to the schools to help save the children
they started running down there to see
if they could be of any kind of help it
was their neighborhood and the police
had somehow really to beat them and
really force them out of the area as the
day progressed and they all had to stay
in shelters or in hotels or with friends
for a few days but what did they do
secretly because they knew all the
little roads and they knew how to go
around the barriers or they knew how to
talk with an officer who would not first
one to let them through they will talk
to me to say well my cat needs food I
need to go so they would sneak back home
to be home because their home their
apartment was the place where they felt
safe even after the terrible events of
in September 11 and what happened though
with the women that I interviewed south
of the towers who had been south of the
towers those were not rested and down
there those were women who were
commuters mothers all of them they lived
in Staten Island the lifting New Jersey
they lived somewhere westchester they
all worked in the financial district
some work today at the Museum of Jewish
heritage at those offices and as most
commuters do as those of you who are
from New York may have experienced
yourselves people take the train come to
work all they might know is maybe the
next daily a block away where they get
their salad or sandwich for lunch but
they don't venture out to walk around
and to look because all they need to do
especially if there are young mothers as
soon as it's five o'clock they take
their back they run to the subway and
they go home so what happened on
September 11 in the late morning they
were in the southern very southern tip
of the island the towers fell the
subways didn't work there was this huge
cloud of dust that came towards them
many of them thought they would would
not they would choke because there was
so much dust in the air and they didn't
know their surroundings they had no idea
where to go they were trapped but their
instinct told them to go home to their
children so these stories where we are
incredibly powerful because these women
really some of them it took some of them
a day or two to get home and to figure
out either by water or maybe by finding
through a friend the Brooklyn Bridge or
even to to queue up in front of one of
the public phones that where they open
the cell phones didn't work but to give
news
to the to the families that the mothers
were still alive so these were really
really powerful stories to compare to
show how that was for me that the topic
how how important home are feeling safe
at home how important that is yeah and
then after that I had another project
that I'm still working on that's the
Henry now and project angry now and was
some of you may have looked him up he
has been dead now for 20 years I should
know he was a Dutch priest it was gay
openly gay he was a Roman Catholic
priest and he probably because of where
he came from he was a very unusual
priest who he he would he would walk and
talk with Nobel Prize winners and and
speak at Harvard or teach at Harvard and
Yale and not to them as much as he would
work with people with disabilities or
people who of any shapes and sizes and
the project that I helped to create and
we're 20 interviewers and we will be
shaped how we would go about it was on
the occasion of an anniversary of his
sudden death he died in his 60s to show
what an unusual person he was in how in
what unusual ways he had touched the
lives of such a wide range of people
because his home in his last 10 years
was in a community with severely
severely disabled people and
he was taking care of one of these this
is a community where so-called
able-bodied healthy people live with
so-called severely disabled people and
so we identified both the the people who
he influenced and who influenced him
intellectually all over the world built
in European in in the US and we talked
and tried to find also ways how to
interview these people who some of them
have really a hard time to articulate
the sentence and can articulate these
sentences many times with the help of an
assistant and so this this was a very
very beautiful project and still is and
I'm grateful I could be part of that one
and after that then as I mentioned in
the hour before i took now for seven
years a day job that gave me a paycheck
and health insurance and now I'm
freelancing again and I'm doing our
history projects like I'm so happy to be
part of the one that that sadie is
conducting it
historical society about mixed heritage
and I also work for private clients
people call me and I'm going to do
Europe now to interview three different
people who were somebody hires me to
interview their old aunt or their
grandfather and to somehow then either
make a nice out your story out of it or
video or whatever their budget allows
yeah and that's my journey on going I
hope talk about how you market yourself
a little bit for the private clients are
they trying and